welcome to this special edition of
hannity i'm trey gowdy in tonight for
sean
with thanksgiving just days away top
democrats across the country stand ready
and able
to tell you exactly what you can and
cannot do
even if they are unwilling to follow
their own rules
and nothing is off limits pennsylvania's
health secretary just announced a ban
on alcohol sales beginning this
wednesday at 5
pm the state's governor tom wolf imposed
an
in-home mask mandate anytime residents
have a visitor
in their dwelling a similar
recommendation is being used in nevada
forcing residents to wear masks inside
and outside
at all times when away from home a
statewide 10 p.m curfew
is now in effect in california for
everyone in california
except of course governor gavin newsom
newark new jersey is under a 10-day
emergency advisory lockdown
and the rest of the state is facing a
10-person limit
on indoor gatherings governor phil
murphy is even
encouraging family members not to hug
each other
governor murphy's rules apply to
everyone
except of course governor murphy himself
who recently enjoyed a mask-free night
out
with his family at a local restaurant
meanwhile governor's organs governor
kate brown
is now urging residents in her state to
call the police and report any and all
violations
watch this do you want people calling
the police on their neighbors not
emergency lines or 9-1-1
look this is no different than what
happens if there's a party down the
street and it's keeping everyone awake
what do neighbors do they call law
enforcement
because it's too noisy like that could
be a yes
yes yes remember
this is the same governor who allowed
portland to descend
into anarchy for weeks and weeks i kid
you not
governor kate brown wants you to call
the police
if you see too many family members
gathered at a neighbor's house
but whatever you do don't get the police
involved when there's looting
and writing and the federal courthouse
is on fire
or under assault but even that may not
be as
asinine as governor cuomo receiving an
emmy award for his covet 19
briefings